so this is crackdown one yeah white
showing me crackdown was running on Xbox
one X this is the enhanced version in 4k
so you know I played crackdown pretty
recently I got some single-player and
some multiplayer under my belt I really
want to talk about multiplayer but the
thing that was nagging me about
single-player was it's just like
crackdown one wish hear me I know is
what people are asking for it's what I
hope for going into it but there's
there's two reasons why I'm disappointed
so if I'm honest this footage isn't
terribly different from what we're
seeing here of crackdown 3 I don't know
I you talk about like a visual style
right visual style I think you know the
yeah for all the things visual style
entails yes and I'm not saying that
necessarily like it's bad looking right
but it's it's hardly different like
indistinguishable in many ways yeah
maybe there's yeah there's some like
blue lighting effect going on here some
like you know like there's some stuff
happening that wasn't possible in 360
and I don't think was implemented and
the Xbox one X backwards compatibility
version of the original right but I feel
like I'm in the same city kind of
looking at the same stuff
shooting robots this time instead of
people is it a is it a thing of like art
style not necessarily the comic book
outline kind of style but the way in
which the world is like built and
presents it for all those reasons it
feels like I am playing the first game
again mhm right and when I you know pop
back and I start looking at this I'm
like I'm kind of reaffirmed in that
feeling which right going back to what I
was saying before that's kind of what I
was asking for really like we all
remember crackdown is being just a you
know honestly like a really fun power
fantasy right and that escalated you
were leaping up buildings leaping off
buildings like just doing like the
wildest but my other problem with
crackdown 3 single player' is that when
you start the game you
really have any of those abilities
awesome and that's to be expected
but it dawned on me that Wow as much as
I want to play where I ended up in
crackdown again I don't want to play the
start of crackdown again right
I mean what about like make submission
structure though because the thing is
the thing that you're talking about is
like oh it's almost indistinguishable
from crackdown one and you've said this
earlier is that maybe that's what kind
of people are looking for right but and
maybe that's that's also kind of what
I'm looking for out of crackdown single
players but the thing that I want is you
know it could be they could ask you an
objective to say destroy five of these
damn things or whatever but if it's
built in a way that makes me cleverly
utilize my unique abilities to get to
that point to complete those objectives
I mean that's kind of what I'm looking
for in the single-player but I didn't
see anything that you're hoping for why
they put me at the start of the game and
it's basically like you're a nobody
you're just a cop right and hey here's
this city full of crime that's happened
and people that are trying to like take
over districts so just go out there and
find salt drive and pick up icons and
everything I went to is literally just
like mini strongholds all over the place
did you not get any like mid mid point
in the game so they put me about I don't
know I would guess halfway through the
game like even there really isn't much
of a story to tell it's basically like
you go to a district you encounter a new
gang you know okay this gang is part of
this you know crime syndicate or
whatever in gang the when I was looking
at the map though it's it looks like
that traditional open-world structure
where it's like complete five of these
missions and then a big boss will pop up
and that's how you kind of you will
activate an event in that region and
then you take care of that event and
you've cleared in now that's your
territory where ever is it more of that
like territory control
yes tile yeah and you know you're
basically free to go where you want and
find those territories you want to take
over
I will say one thing that's nice is that
you're no longer you know fighting
against racial stereotypes under
fighting against like I think here it's
a group of sorry environmentalists but I
think environmentalists or maybe maybe
not maybe just people who are like
trying to do stuff with is this the one
where they're trying to mind like some
kind of new substance or whatever yeah
yeah it's just like some kind of drug
that they're gonna source or something I
don't know sure yeah I mean all super
important details I can't wait to find
out but so you're a narc in this game
you're cop you're still a cop yeah what
kind of sad it depends what kind of
crimes yeah so are you do you feel you
don't feel motivated to kind of at least
one what you saw you don't feel motivate
to like I need to crackdown on these
fools or because because that's that's
also a driving force as much as you know
as much as using these abilities and
causing destruction is I think we've
gotten to the point where there's extra
motivation expected to be pulled from
you when it comes to story or at least
characters your place in an open world
has much more meaning now than it did
back back in 2007 yeah and I again
you're a cookie cutter nobody the intro
sequence is a bunch of you know hoorah
like we're gonna go out that we're gonna
stop some crime like blah blah blah you
know Terry Crews vampa and stuff and
like that's all well and good and then
it's just like okay agent you're out in
the field and it's like I felt this
sense this overwhelming sense of deja vu
and it was like that's not what I want
you know and I'll tell you what I do
want and maybe what set singleplayer up
for disaster in my experience was a
multiplayer
which was immediately awesome showing me
not even just like what crackdown is
capable of in terms of the concept that
we all think about but the fact that
it's running in the cloud enables it to
have full destructibility and that just
like completely changes how you use
those powers you're talking about how
about missions that give me a way to use
my powers and some you know in a new
context right for new reasons and with
new purpose that's yeah so you can see
anything oh yeah a lot of people like to
rag on the the phrase you know the power
of the cloud but I feel like talking to
you about the multiplayer is that it's
actually put to use this is actually a
thing that changes the way in which the
game plays so but why is that like
what's that what's the setup for
multiplayer and why is destruction like
impacting is the way you play so they
put us in this one stage which is called
like the Hall of Champions or something
like that yeah but it's essentially a
thing with like huge verticality lots of
like open awnings on the side of
buildings and stuff and there's a lot of
launch pads as well so as you are doing
things like hitting a launch pad you can
use your rocket launcher and blow your
way through a building and fly through
it in midair you don't get the jump on
an enemy that you know is on the other
side oh come on I'm gonna get this
pulled up alright good so look at look
at how tall this yeah you've seollal you
feel small in relation to the
environment which is something I like a
lot and open-world kind of games that
what do you want to cause destruction to
move around very fast this isn't an
open-world really yeah
and I've granted adjusting to what this
does is a multiplayer like took you some
time so my footage probably isn't the
best but there are some things made to
help you out like you have a pretty good
idea of where an enemy is because of
their within a certain distance you can
tag them and lock-on you can even see
them through buildings which is crucial
given that firing through a building can
sometimes be the best way to hit
somebody like with Splash Damage example
so as our matches you know kept going is
everyone started to get a bit better and
a bit more frantic and I just couldn't
wait to get back into the next match oh
yeah
like I wish they were twice as long you
know like it just felt it's so different
from anything else and so fun yeah and
to support all this destructibility you
know Microsoft's cloud stuff like they
were telling me that there's about the
power of 12 Xbox ones like the launch
yeah per instance of this yeah because
the way in which it works if you're not
familiar with the cloud or whatever it's
that it delegates physics calculations
to two systems off-site so you can have
this huge scale destruction that's not
putting so much pressure on your local
hardware yes we're at parallel
computation yeah yeah and that makes
something like this very possible which
is exclusively in multiplayer so you
don't get that kind of scale of
destruction in single-player no and so
I'm doing stuff like this right I'm
flying through the air I'm shooting my
way through buildings I'm like you know
destroying my opponents in ways I never
really have and not in a multiplayer
game before and then they just plop me
in a single player yeah and it's like
okay you're you're a powerless dude here
you go
there's this a straw it feels like
talking to you and watching even just
watching the footage alone there's a
strong juxtaposition between what you're
capable of in both single-player and
multiplayer and I kind of in a way like
playing the single-player or playing
multiplayer kind of dilutes the odd that
you would have gone from playing the
open world single players illustrates
how old-school the single-player really
is right and I know that's what people
want again I thought I wanted that too
I'm sure people in the comments are
gonna say yeah seriously I went there
excited to see that again and then after
playing this I was like I yeah I didn't
really know what I wanted and I don't
know if I could have ever put my finger
on this being the thing yeah though the
multiplayer aspect yeah and in a way
like multiplayer can show cases this is
how crackdown can exist in a the current
generation yeah and then when you have a
single player that's very old-school
that's like oh man like what if that
what if you uses some of the great
things that you did multi-pin
multiplayer and applied those the
single-player and that kind of I guess
that's not happening and it's not coming
through at least unfortunately and I
only played I'd say about 90
so this single player calculating you
know maybe that could open up into a lot
more stuff I don't know but I dare say
I'm not going to bother to try to find
out maybe I'll wait for someone to tell
me they're like oh yeah the game gets
really good that's 40 hours I mean even
like it's like after an hour like this
thing or two hours this thing opens up
that you couldn't see coming from the
beginning right cool they're there
totally is that potential but the moment
I get my hands on this game this is all
I'm gonna want to engage
so there's still lots of we need to
learn the game comes out February 15th
it's really not that far away crackdown
3 is real uh yeah right it was announced
in what 2014 yeah a long time ago it was
just called crackdown and maybe
appropriately so so yeah I'm really
curious to see how people are going to
react to this to the original game and
what that you know honestly what it's
going to mean for for cloud gaming I I
think like so many people I find myself
thinking about cloud gave me like yeah
it's a nice thought but like come on I
want to see it in action I want to see
it do something that's there like a I
didn't even believe that that it would
be right I don't that it would be strong
enough and compelling enough for me to
say like maybe I don't need dedicated
hardware maybe I want to just have
something that plays in the cloud and
this gives me more confidence like
granted I need an Xbox one hex or PC to
play this based on the cloud but you
know we're looking at the future we're
streaming devices are going to be
getting smaller and smaller integrated
into things and if this is what's
capable given today's internet and with
Microsoft's infrastructure of granite
they're one of the biggest with their
Azure like you know server structure but
still like it's a model to false yeah
it's a good showcase of what it's
capable of and yeah I'd love to see
where it can take gaming for developers
and for us as consumers were always
looking for new ways to play and
experience games right it's coming up I
hope I haven't diminished your
excitement no it's it's it's all good
I'm I've been trying to keep up with
whatever's whatever preview coverage has
come out of crackdown 3 because it's me
it's been weird in that I don't feel
like it's being made that big of a deal
even though it's Microsoft exclusive
even though we've been like a lot of
people been waiting for this for years
it still feels like oh it's coming out
in a couple weeks like really late my
hunch is maybe that's because they know
the single-player isn't going to freely
get anyone's attention for long and
they're probably weary of being like hey
the cloud the cloud because I think like
like me like I was describing we're not
ready as a group to really just accept
the cloud for what it is I think there's
a lot of doubt there's a lot of
questions and for Microsoft alike
downplay the game they're going to let
it speak for itself okay cool that's
what's up hello oh it's crackdown 3 hi
crackdown 3
[Music]